back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
well who's got it that's a nobody scared
you scared go to church dude I wanna
pull that Tom Hanks hugging on them
koalas then post loosed a million
followers and then your [ __ ] boy here
Mustafa
what is awesome I'm just Albert what did
he score it yeah just on PR stud dude if
you really got it die that's what I'm
saying really got it [ __ ] where these
dyers at yeah that's up dude when it
comes I see nobody coming yeah we have
where the coffins think I haven't seen
one hearse go by dude help that you tall
jazz player the best player he got it
right he post videos like I feel fine
yeah how's things wrong not that he's
fine yeah he said he lost about four
pounds and he's doing great that's
actually more shred a little more energy
yeah says he can see better something
higher
bring it on dude I kind of want it yeah
that's the thing where are the day where
the ill where the dead where the people
scream and jumping out of windows
well there's it hit you know it's the
Boomer vibe so hits you old people the
hold people are on the gram so you're
not really gonna see it oh so you need
like they're the kids of filming I guess
if you want to see that [ __ ] I don't
know how about how deep CNN wants to get
oh yeah how dark seamen are you do you
guys know anywhere that's dead you don't
know anybody that's dead I mean if I'm
people yeah okay my bad
yeah but deal I mean who's got it that's
what I'm wondering all rats had it for
years now really four years ago
[Laughter]
dude you look like the third wet bandit
you got Corona for years you have a food
truck that sells batsu Tom Hanks has it
address Alba has it hit you someone
don't worry about that bite yeah
don't worry about that bad so you can
get it boy dude you definitely came back
from [ __ ] Hawaii weekend at Bernie's
dude [ __ ] is out Bernie's be on a bender
for months you're like slope ashy dude
[Laughter]
snap into a t-cell hey anyone push the
product harder oh yeah dude I would
break them open and I would squeeze all
the grease out and then yeah I feel sick
thinking about it dude I think I Crone
when I was a kid why would you do that
oh yeah hey do you remember Macho Man
and spider-man oh dude he was full of
Corona and just [ __ ] the most jacked
human being you've ever seen bring that
[ __ ] up Nick and he's like oh yeah he's
like doctor diagnose his neck he's not
human though he had extra veins I feel
like in his car and he would just put
him into his body dude he had to be
blowin through dude he must have done
every steroid in the world for the whole
he would look at him I saw there was
some video that we didn't use submission
and they call it Theo Macho Man Randy
average
[Laughter]
dude he was so jacked he's my favorite
wrestler dude really been the warrior
yeah all the time
yeah they were nuts man he put paint on
his face very strange I mean Jake the
snake yeah that documentary about him
was great yeah who's got it man of the
that's a genius got it oh yeah that's
true we could lose a lot lose a lot of
singers they said almost two million
seniors are gonna die yeah dudes kind of
like the purge like why would they take
everybody's grandparents dude think of
all the meemaw's pawpaws what do you
guys call them in Vietnam it depends
there's my binoy where's Mike that's hot
hey have some respect but no yeah I like
you have anybody knows we're gonna lose
all my banana don't care yes and I do
care all my Binoy are gone [ __ ]
oh my Benoist are gone I'm here you know
what you know what Benoist do you know
what they do
oh you know up annoys do what they die
oh that's what old people do bro we're
all gonna be there well I hate to be
shitty about wrong gonna be there to put
a smile on and she's closer my Chin's
closer than all this but worried she's
all worried about Corona it's looking
more than you guys just a little bit
more than that what's what's going on
I didn't give anyone a hug here right I
did these you did those these yeah you
got your carpal tunnel thing on to uh
see ya that's another added protection
more layer don't think that [ __ ]
wristband you're wearing has [ __ ] I
know
thank you Tony who trains like a bat
yeah just wait for a bat to fall here
[ __ ] wrist you make a soup
[Laughter]
oh yeah I like bats do they're cute what
I love that really a bat there's some in
Colorado dude do you look like a hit man
for a cafeteria that breaks into the
back of a mashed potato a tour guide for
West Hollywood that's where I first got
started so jump on in boy and this is
where we exit the vehicle come on in if
you want to die here is e my get
yourself one get yourself a Zima
understand this from white hmm they
don't don't hate the Hawaiian but I look
at that Hawaiian I go you have nice
little Hawaiian trip yes I did Brendan
yes dude I don't know I don't know I bet
you find something to complain about
like the waters too [ __ ] blue bro the
water give people man yeah it was K was
pretty blue yeah bro it's crazy over
there people nice to you yeah people so
nice people were extremely calm - mm-hmm
so called no worry about the virus they
got other stuff going sir yeah no Isis
don't know [ __ ] mass shootings no
there would be like yeah like there'll
be a Matt like somebody might drive by
and just throw a bunch of weed at
everybody if you throw mine Apple to
hardly get upset yeah it was really yeah
just people chilling over there a lot of
missing people over there too
where do they go it's an island they go
there man they go there you know it's
just that kind of place where like a lot
of people sleeping in hammocks by the
beach like just no are they really
missing then no I think a lot of people
like if you walk around I'm like hey
have you guys seen Patrick everybody but
oh I think so you know like a few months
ago yeah we had like a wanted poster of
a dude that was kind of look like
Brendan almost but just like looking
back towards the camera
and you're like hey have you guys seen
this guy's like oh yeah yeah a few weeks
ago bro you surf him wrong yeah
I didn't serve daddy I could get out
there
I just can't surf yeah you just stay on
the board
I mean you boogie board bro you boogie
board that's cool dude I would be on the
biggest board out there like the van
only board that had a horn on it he's a
paddleboard dude it's our birthday week
brah
dude getting older fighting off Corona
happy birthday man
I know happy birthday first man yep and
you're right after me dude well your
birthday was yesterday
no my birthday maybe a little something
for you it's a wine bag and that card
open the card you thought there was food
in there brother
hot fries gotta get right to it you
thought it was a bad read it yeah come
on now this says happy birthday booby
boy thanks for supporting thing thanks
for being supportive and introducing me
to new friends like Kat and chin and
Chappell I've never had a black friend
before hope hope hope hope your hope
your is next year a good one grammar
here but hope your is next year a good
one
that's what you wrote here what's your
hope your is next year eighth dwarf
spell II okay hope your is next year a
good one
now that's not what it says I swear on
my life thanks reducing new people and
they're not a black friend before hope
door is next you're a good sleep easy
Reedy that is Reedy dude let your mom
spellcheck for you right there boy card
why did you set this tone it's a small
card again through getting through the
card Brendan read it am i off I made the
black friend thing I knew it reads
perfectly clear I think you're right
hope your is next year a good was a
little off roading for your CTE that's
all that was I knew what you meant
I get it I had to get that order bro had
to buy give you a side eight-by-ten of
me hey I went away hard to get the
double XL killer merge life I can how
are you happy for you no oh what is this
man some dope kicks man I told y'all to
get some dope kicks rock onstage nothing
like a fresh pair of j's these Riddler's
huh the pine greenies yeah yeah if you
feeling frosty you can you can put the
red laces in which I like but Wow black
it was crisp that's Christmas Footwear
huh I give to George wait what what well
that's a double bingo
pretty good in your card my misspelled
but the grammars no big deal I would pop
that count dude oh there's two of them
[Laughter]
awesome one wasn't good enough
this is frosty is fun and we got you
something too
cat new car well last week you guys were
talking about a cookie cake am I gonna
break my diet for this again you are I'm
sure okay you mean every day I'm done
are you really no you look great I was
gonna say something look like that yeah
[Music]
damn mrs. field said [ __ ] Corona made it
and because Wow and because people hate
here and chewing on mic while you enjoy
it we have another little surprise
enjoy some enjoy some cake hey brother
surprise you flew my mom and if you feel
my mom informed ever I'm gonna freak out
I'm gonna freak out dude if you flew my
[ __ ] mom in we're not getting along
right now I'm gonna freak out dude
dude if you flew Patrick in from Hawaii
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
thank you this video what's up guys yeah
I know yeah yeah it's our birthday sorry
we both have Corona
we both have Corona we're celebrating
thank you
happy birthday to you happy birthday
[Music]
thank you guys living one look at that
I'll be 37 I'll be 40 40 oh you're 40
[Laughter]
and you just where the actual bra when
I'm 40 Thank You Man thank you guys for
coming it's nice last night and they
they want us to prep something else for
you okay so kind of mind no we came up
with yeah remix when I said remix
doom-doom doom-doom doom-doom
Duke in the sing do birthday fight over
wait I gotta go black rifle copy I'm
ready to go I need a sponsor
I am a monster about to open up with
this at all of our concerts what was
contagious browser our aegis think of
them girls that are Instagram famous
hungry like I'm fresh off keto see and
read like Andrew Santino you tried but
you couldn't beat him you don't want to
smoke like Joey
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but you
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah it's our birthday tour around
the competition are those called whitish
[Laughter]
but the volume get a little balcony
focus on the singing you can't wait for
them to get over let me get one more
piece it's my birthday
Wow Thank You Man wow what a brute was
fun I got this sweet freakin bday my
favorite cake seal gave me one of those
free t-shirts this is cool man the
double XL sir they cost more fabric in
the last in the lab they do that's a
double fabric the last I see another big
girl thumbing down a cookie saying I'm
actually in Excel
instead of what okay about to wear
assless chaps a Lakers game do you look
like Megan the donkey white those boys
let's see your ass so bad then you got
it out you told me too well
gotta gots the boys you think they drove
all the way down into their Corona times
do Corona times just not to see your ass
just to sing those [ __ ] tunes yes I
think they were good guys what do you
think of the music Chappelle you sing oh
they were great I wanted to join yeah
yeah I got no black people I'm like well
let's get down like these subs we can go
further then CW zombie zebra you take
them out on the VT this [ __ ] would be
lit chin what did you think of that
other singing actually rank it if you
had to rank the singers like seriously
rank it ya know mess around
yeah they were awesome by the way they
seemed like awesome guys really nice I
feel really good I would say part run
one of those guys came from Vegas last
night really 10.5 they've got a they've
got a pretty good rate but they were
happy to get together they said these
trying times they were like we haven't
been together for a while we're we're
looking for an excuse and I'm sure
they're gonna party it up to me they're
trying to get out of the house listen
they did a [ __ ] five-minute don't
think they seemed like gay men to me not
few of them work you think so I'll do
how many were four it was a four or five
as for its quartet a half quartet how
many's in accord to happen happen
between Brock
how many quartets in a gallon they were
great though man I didn't know what was
really great or not Brendon because you
keep saying they weren't no I I'm just
curious birthday man you're ruining it
no I'm doing well your shirt rude but
hey the thing is is I just have skin I
love it I mean I like the effort I just
feel like your joins are very hard to
get can't buy him anyway thank you so
within yeah the Jays dude those are
Jordan wants pie really when one pines
Dan
I didn't know that also make you dunk vo
really mm-hmm
wow thank you from Corona oh definitely
I could see that swag whoa
Wow brother hey ever smell the inside of
that one I got some real that's that's a
brand new shoe smell on my favorite whoo
oh boy oh dude don't get that hunker in
there cuz like a hot glue gun you should
just make these in the party will
Chinese people move oh oh let's see no
fast words 30 minutes there's a [ __ ]
line of code CEO doing it from back
there oh
three-point shooter dude yeah that
3-point sniffer they used to call you
like the Steve David Scott 3d young man
sometimes gonna be hard to sleep with
with the crazy world we live everywhere
these days I can't even sleep it's like
who's that Oh viral me doctor and then
you know what you're not come I adore
you know what I don't answer it they
keep mocking cuz I'm sleeping oh you do
huh knocking but Hank I mean can I sleep
on helix brah if you like sleep has a
quiz that takes just two minutes to
complete and match your body type I just
put down thick he's sleeping yes I said
he sounded offensive plus-sized send me
a king we got plus-sized I said and you
and Liz oh yeah if you like sin he's
soaking wet if I'm gonna eat somebody if
you like a mattress that's really soft a
firm you sleep on your side or you like
to sleep on your back with us eat listen
man helix does it all
they make specifically for your body
type let me you they just said a soft
man yeah they send me the corn they say
corn or flour
and let me buy you asleep let me buy you
a mattress
Helix sleep was even awarded number one
best or on mattress pick up to now 19
and 2020 by GQ all right we love this
bed all my guests sleep on that bed in
the big old crib just go to helix sleep
calm /k ATS take their two minutes sleep
quiz and they'll match you a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of yo he's so can we sleep they
have a 10 year warranty you get a try it
out for 100 nights risk-free then they
even pick it up for you so you don't
have to worry about it try it out Felix
is offering you king of sing listeners
up to 200 hours off all mattresses even
the plus size one for the big boys and
free pillows for the listeners at helix
sleep comm /ka TSS helix sleep comm
slash kt slash tech 80s for up to $200
dollar good night sweet princes man i
don't feel safe in here sometimes dude
honestly in here I just had homie in
here do I don't feel safe in here I
don't feel safe at home it feels like
the purge right now everybody wine out
everybody at home who's a grocery store
I went to the grocery store it's chaos
really it's chaos dude but you want to
be safe at home and guess what now home
security dude you better step your game
up with simply safe it's everything you
need in a home security system
its award-winning protection all right
it's like having a real life pants or
roam your backyard and tells you when
people are coming over two-time winner
of the Cena Editors Choice Award simply
safe blankets your entire home with
safety up you barely noticed do I know
you
you barely notice that it's there what's
truly remarkable you can set up the
system all by yourself you don't need
somebody you don't need big Randall to
come over you don't need a little Thomas
or a little Larry brother Jerry and all
your snacks playsets the cam so yeah you
don't need somebody coming over and
hitting on your wife over there but I
got a wrench out yeah and a hard-on dude
you know what else is weird
I tried buying a panther ii just patrol
my house and yeah so i like you're
simply safe dude get up yeah if you want
a good panther bra oh yeah you're
looking at 2500 and it's only 50 cents a
day was simply safe yeah no courage it
takes 30 minutes it's half an hour tops
if you're slow
that's half a while 50 cents no
contracts what are we doing protect your
homes can't afford a panther you go to
simply save calm /ke 80s that's simply
safe calm /k 80s today and you'll get
free shipping and a 60 day risk-free
trial now the only risks is if there's
any risks in your area and you'll know
about them with simply safe you got
nothing to lose except for your house
yeah so go to freedom go to simply safe
calm / K 80s no probably not
the government says run supposed to do
anything I probably haven't meet up with
someone at a park or something maybe do
frisbee if I have enough things to clean
her up each time we throw it back and
forth what are you guys doing dude are
you guys what are you worried about this
at the house or what are you guys doing
thriving just working out doing our
thing do a lot of podcast and then my
girl was threw me a surprise birthday
dinner but really you know but the
restaurant shut down she had an invite
for you but he got cancelled yesterday
morning when was this supposed to be it
was supposed to be Wednesday night
daliyah Rogan Callen I didn't get
invited Todd Feldman yeah I promise yep
when was she gonna invite me because
that day was confirmed so she sent you
an email sent you an email bro you're in
Hawaii playing grab-ass sniffing shoes
not to my emails even you might have
sent one different goddess you did me
you'll have another person that you know
the same similar like just Theo somebody
deal Carter dude I've had some [ __ ]
real killer shoes alright there's Casey
Anthony ones with the kids handprint
around the ankle now it's too much now
it's too much should we get in some
debate club
that's a bad attitude I do I love my
life
dude this is fantastic I feel like the
most positive guy during the corona time
really I felt like those guys had some
darkness [ __ ] those guys flew from Las
Vegas Brendan no no probably on
broomsticks what one did to get here one
flew well or did they take the Train
Nick do we know they all drove
separately including the guy who came
from Vegas we had Burbank Temecula Vegas
and they did it huh I hope you tip them
well bro we will we will think they got
paid their rate and I want to make sure
they performed and they did and now
they'll get there too I wonder if they
everything people get them in for sex or
something I bet people bring those kind
of people in a lot for sex mmm swishy
the guy in Vegas yeah because if you're
thinking about it you're like who can we
get that would come in here potentially
someone might do sex with some money
that was out of our budget
yeah Haley you can hire them cowboy an
angel boys the other thing is look up
the website but the other thing is if
those guys went on for if they want it
for an hour that would be he'll be hell
if they like they had a concert I blow
my [ __ ] brain I am but not if they go
past three songs got my bike my breaking
point was three in oh yeah great great
you're fun no no don't you twist it they
were fantastic four three after that and
they're trying to hang out there trying
to linger that's why I fellas all right
man we've had fun it was my birthday -
Bryn's come on whoo stay long I wouldn't
mind one more song should we put him in
the culture Cordish oh dude they
definitely have kind of a throwback vibe
I thought the one guy was uh the
surprising guy was the little baritone
guy the smuggler he was like they're
kind of small or God but ya know
baritone yeah maybe back like the one
rapping the widest [ __ ] I've ever seen
my life they were I thought that they
were pretty good baby got back was good
I like the little brow song that's great
yeah they actually had baby back
in their repertoire already because I
definitely obviously want them to do a
little Iggy Azalea for us but not enough
time to do a four four person
arrangement or two attitude me club is
from Phil Phil looks just like it just
feel look like he does he fell yeah
consumed who do y'all think that he
looks like who's he
one of the quartet dudes oh he does a
little bit huh but he also looks a
little bit like who is it oh I know you
talking about you do yeah that's singer
right who is it that's here Luke Louis
Capaldi yeah Capaldi that's what I'm
thinking yeah he looks a little bit like
goo Goo's Cavalli I don't even think
that that is Luis Capaldi is like
probably one of the hottest Scottish or
Irish singers there always is a young
man he sounds Italian it's Lewa did you
see mix history is all oh he does look a
little bit like that and Tim doing he's
a good dude
I see the Tim Dylan mm-hmm that's who it
is
looks like kind of slim Dylan I feel
like yeah buddy looks like Louis Capaldi
a little if Louis kind of joined like it
got any more like a boy band yeah and uh
didn't have as much swagger kinda maybe
here we go yeah he looks yeah he looks
yeah he looks like Louis Capaldi's like
other brother the brother that did
science or gang what's up Brendan what's
up Theo listen you know do my part
social distancing but no sports to watch
running on a podcast waiting for some
new episodes and I just found myself
googling and googling and stumbled
across a little King under sting and I'd
love to get you guys his opinion on the
sniper tell me what you think about this
now I don't know if Steve Kerr was off
that sauce or what
when came time to name this last child
here but um and what do y'all think
about Steve Kerr naming his kid Oh
Japanese whiskey now the best bet might
be to have Chappelle read this name haha
but he keeps burning their dices trying
to say it too fast fellas and Brendon
just pretend like you're ordering some
some more Japanese Wow Steve Kerr named
his kid
Nick Kerr you had to say you know it's
Nick but you had to say it yeah I don't
you would know no I wouldn't
called text David dude I don't know
about this what do you I mean I have no
I don't even who to ask in the room of
the players you like oh what's the
baby's name is like Nick well that's
cool he's like my last name's car I
better be Nick cop
what do you guys think ahh let's go to
the culture corner is this what do you
do - you shut the kid down do you change
his name or Nicholas Kurt Nicholas Carr
yeah how old is he he probably struggled
in school I'll tell you that much yeah I
hope you didn't go to all-black school
and hate chabela new dad Steve curry and
I go on all-black school he's around a
bunch of black he was taking em for the
base round by age
it's you know yeah but even if it was
like it was like a private school or
something I'm sure he ran into some some
people had some questions about it being
interesting at Steve Kerr named his son
Nick oh it's a neck-and-neck ooh
people are kind of like yeah maybe it
was this grandpa's name look I think
sometimes it's a way to change the tide
you know this is Nick Kerr it just feels
so natural to you when you say it a
little bit just glides out Brina you say
it more all the time dude
and you've been saying it probably
around the house to your children yeah
dude look at these little knickers I
know yeah Brendan get it together dude
look at it oh look you just be frowning
right now smooth like this glitter when
you say just roll wow you've changed man
sneakers changed I guess great [ __ ]
question though are you just trying to
get back in the league you know it's
crazy man well this little twink himself
what about this now there's a lot of
probably arm
a lot of Asian names that have that have
some different type of connotation to
them don't they like it's not like a lot
of their last name in ikka like the
whiskey not to my understanding or my
knowledge yeah Brenna's just trying to
find a way to say it akid who break into
your house and steal a recipe the haters
are grime like all the money but he took
our [ __ ] salt and pepper
field looks like the yin-yang orphan
[Laughter]
teddy yeah yeah man it's out there it's
good I'm stuck on slope ashy oh my god
coke all the same lemme go you got it
tighten up man you gotta tighten up
so King understand it then let's go to
the rest of the group here what do you
guys think on Steve Kerr's son's name
Nick Kerr I'll sting it there's so many
names this is coming from a Nick this is
coming from a real Nick over here Jen
what do you think I I feel like he just
didn't think about saying the two words
together and he really likes the name
Nick but I was stinger - I would think
about it more in sting it nobody goes by
Nicholas has - Nicky Nick Nicholas for
sure Nicky yeah must be friends I like
your attitude cat
draymond Green might have a problem
David West I think whatever problem
David Western here's like the most
racist player in the or like oh like a
racist guy really you wouldn't yeah I
mean nobody's really gonna get into
supporting the name I don't think maybe
a couple people I don't think anybody
gives a [ __ ] yeah I think you couldn't
have both names on the back of the
jersey probably right from like we had a
guy growing up we didn't have him but
was around and he wrote the end where he
had he made these hats right on the
front it said the n-word across the
front but on the back it said just
joking across the back so it was like I
bet they sold it to hazel to ask it he
only made two you sold out minutes but
it's not a good habit do you still have
that Steve Kerr son I've never had it
but yes and got me a couple hats anyway
yeah danger sting it I'm gonna have to
feel comfortable kinging anything yeah I
do not either yeah all we want and
Brendon obviously Brendan voted with
with its behavior what else you got what
else you got familiar face I'm Brandon
what's up Theo everyone in the booth
chin Nick Kat answer my DM to Boyd G
over from this past weekend so basically
what's going down is I was working on a
show in New York
this guy 50-cent creates it I don't know
if you've ever heard of him but
basically they shut down so that's who I
have nothing to do all day long so I
went to Rhode Island where my parents
live and I created I can't talk so King
under sting it tick tock wow thanks guys
Gang Gang buzz buzz
he created tick tockia so he developed
the have tick tick tock yeah I guess
Johnny did who does our booking
billionaire uh he is gonna be on a new
stars TV show I think I do know that I
do know that actually I love how he
dropped 50 cent legs bit hey y'all may
be heard I'm 50 cent also ja Rule slide
my DM so be cool dude I told him act
like a cocky prick he didn't come off
well there I will stories it's pretty
ridiculous
people what every time he's laying Abed
shirtless it's all kind of rap lyrics
look at me now yes tattooed on his
shoulder yeah I'm getting paper yes
tattooed very bizarre what was this
question again I think it is astronomy I
don't care tick-tock
King under stinging we're too old for
tick-tock right I think so man I got
enough social media I don't need another
thing is anybody in here
tick-tock are you cat you're kind of
young enough for the tick-tock no you're
too old for it you think I think I'm old
enough to watch it I don't know if I'm
comfortable enough to be on it how is it
different than Instagram just like a
bunch of boomerangs no it's a bunch of
people making like small videos kind of
like musically and vine you stood no it
was musically and it switched to tic-tac
but yeah at vine I think it's the
closest I don't know how how long are
the videos I thought 10 seconds but I
keep seeing one shared on other social
medias that are longer this is the first
time like I'm like okay I'm pretty old I
don't get it is is that the app where
the [ __ ] the boys would like be doing
something then they switch outfits with
the girls yes yes the [ __ ] out of here
JLo and a rat a rat did one that's some
bit [ __ ] that ain't for me man
oh I I've just seen a little bit of it
and I don't mind it really I don't think
I just don't I'm really had a chance to
look at the app really I like some gun I
just know like a lot of young kids are
honest
it literally just came out that
tick-tock in the beginning was
suppressing users they deemed to be ugly
so it was only good-looking people that
were showing up in people's feeds Wow
but here's a JLo and so if you are ugly
you wouldn't so they just like hid the
ugly like shadow band the ugly people
essentially halo and trying to shake it
like Jen in the same white dress you
just can't unsee I was like a viral
thing right dudes were switching outfits
with a girl mhm yes sting uh Tik Tok I'm
just gonna say sting it out just cuz I
don't know about I'm not in it yeah I
spent 37 I feel like I shouldn't be on
there ya feel like I'm gonna sign up and
Chris Hansen a pop out be like you wanna
have a seat yeah have a seat have a seat
have a seat over here at the Four
Seasons where I'm staying for 11 nights
on you guys's tab we worked that out
were cool they call me and talk to you
about it which is nice Nvidia was IA mad
fella you should pay for that all them
[ __ ] kids I saved you can't give me
one night in a hotel all been [ __ ]
kids I say from being their [ __ ] we
were up we gave him one night we didn't
give him 500 did he say 5 I don't know
it was we gave him a couple nights
didn't he thank you but it's the least
you guys do these same children and
what'd he get for it cancelled that's
what he got it's true I feel bad now but
he still doesn't like a youtube show
doesn't do like so bro
he's like you want to have a seat here's
a new show yeah what's it on CW no it's
on YouTube I believe here's a new he
just did there was so there's something
that he's about him the other day
that was my favorite show for a long
time dude
my favorite my favorite is one like the
same dude shut up 3 times like an
episode 1 episode 7 episode 14 episode
32 dude put this guy away for [ __ ] sakes
yeah yeah anything everyone I knew it
I thought you were gonna come out man on
yeah here he goes that's his ticker no
virus update tomorrow I have a seat yeah
look I think Chris is a neat guy I think
he just you know the dark arts will get
you and he gave into doing you know he
was just doing what we all do sometimes
chasing women you know just doing this
and that and all really thought I got
cancelled have a seat mm-hmm
no no he wasn't he I think he was just I
don't know I have no idea was he on the
show what was he on your guys show yeah
he need a [ __ ] to talk about I just what
he was trying to do it was mostly about
the history of To Catch a Predator allow
those repeat someone's favorites I don't
it was it was really funny yeah I liked
him up you didn't ask him what he's
doing no he was he was trying he was at
the moment he was crowdfunding to try to
do his own show I think it had up on
YouTube I don't know if he's doing
anything catching predators but he's
doing he adopted the name have a seat it
was just doing in a Skype interview show
appearance at the moment he's putting up
some numbers times were tough
called have a seat and he's doing yeah
he's a hard worker he has a son I know
that was going to school somewhere think
you might have two sons just like
[ __ ] with those kids one of his sons
is a newscaster somewhere oh really
mm-hmm
and here's somebody hi we didn't get the
rest of that was the last thing we were
talking about - tock tick tock we were
good really yeah I don't know but it
seems like it to me you know it's
dancing it's music it seemed like it's
in your wheelhouse like that cliff some
music and dance do you're racist that's
racist assuming you can dance I didn't
assume that he could
you've seen him death huh I believe he
can thank you thank you Thea yes you've
been jumping in bombs so smooth he's not
an Asian but it's not like honky or
something like agent for honky there is
stuff like that yeah there is honky I'm
pretty sure there's a Korean uh
like super star I know really sorry
honky okay I'm not even kidding how do
you say white devil Oh actually in
Vietnamese there's a name that's
but but then it spelled bi CH but it
looks like [ __ ] there's another one
that is the spelling for house is nga so
people will put and then yeah right next
to it so it looks like a different
what's that mean in Vietnamese it is
someone's name and house but that
English spelling looks like something
else what does it look like then but
yeah what does that mean big space NGO
the way okay nevermind I was just
thinking actual so you're saying yeah so
[ __ ] in word [ __ ] [ __ ] some guy who
definitely is a real does not like black
people who's hiding up in the mountains
right here okay let's be honest here's a
guy who's disguising himself
no which is basically a lot of black
people call it white fire so here's some
guy hiding up there yeah I think I think
I've been saying debate clubs these are
been king under sting it's yours okay
let's get this [ __ ] honky out here
before I ask you I just want to show you
where we're out Valdez Alaska way up
high we ice climbing today so that's
your can you're seeing it ice climbing
stick pic pump pump love you guys
love you man say stay safe dude um it
looks like you just hiking I don't see
any ice do you see the ice there's ice
in front of him Brendan again I think
he's just just hiking who is he in
Runyon Canyon hmm
side of a cliff look at his father yeah
that's some snow ice pick was it ice
picking ice climbing ice climbing man I
think that that stuff is rugged I think
it's tough I'm cool with it I think it's
like fun there's probably no way you're
gonna get infected with anything out
there and there's nothing out there
nothing could even live out the only
thing here's a good time and maybe a
nice fresh slushy
yeah there's Avalanche worries Avalanche
concerns that the polar bears might get
up to your ass yup couple bears uh I
think that this everything else seems
like was he doing it up
Alaska what's up Brendan what's up Theo
I got a king of forcing it for y'all
today but before I ask you guys what I
didn't say did it be a wider sport
ice climbing it's almost Nordic I feel
like that guy could be I mean to get out
on ice and try to get to the top of it
that's really to stick [ __ ] spikes in
the side of the mountain to climb up the
ice yeah it's ballsy man it's brave
those four guys that were singing
they're probably do it yeah but yeah I
think the guys I you notice those
reflective glasses on because I guess
the reflection off that ice is probably
pretty hot
that's the worst so I think it's
probably pretty brave I don't know if I
would like it as much as doing something
more like just climbing like a regular
wall that's like room temperature like a
rock yeah yeah with him climbing over
here on your freaking little piss bricks
over here maybe heavy on the condom bus
central over there I'm gonna say sing it
for me I think it's a singing I applaud
it but for me it's a little too much I
would rather do that solo climbing that
they do then be out on ice no no no a
hard time skateboarding little [ __ ]
climb up a wall free solo style
skateboarding is hard dude okay but our
ropes
with that uh-huh little ruffles on a
skateboard your rollerblader huh little
rollerblade cutoff jean shorts in that n
hat I didn't I think we got one laughs I
didn't buy him it was somebody that's
passing through town that ball and he
made that [ __ ] I couldn't make a hat at
that age man I saw the Hat that's all I
did
and I went like this oh and here's our
last King understand
hey guys Kirk Nikolas from Boulder
Colorado here with one of the worst
starts in humankind history to a new
year what else could possibly go wrong
well this morning Tom Brady announced
that he will no longer be a New England
Patriot it's the end of an era and quite
frankly my mind is blown so well Tom
Brady following the footsteps of LeBron
James to LA my question to you is well
Tom Brady be the new king of LA
qinger stinging gang gang buzz buzz
thanks buzz buzz shot to Boulder
Colorado where your boy went to college
oh yeah buffs huh Bob Central go uh the
sink okay hang out what is it the same
that's the bar we'd hang out low
ceilings tons of hoes oh I've been there
before they're really on the hill don't
know yeah you have the pizza place right
across the street to the ice were on a
bus company out there with my buddy damn
from Boulder to Denver and they got a
full-length medium to full and we got um
and uh we had some legal issues pop up
but yeah I was like party buses you know
you get people to get on there and party
drop him out there and drop him back
all them frat boys but people always
vomit and abortions everything on there
they were doing it all heads missing Jon
Benet style you know she got shut down
the one group I remember had a jonbenét
party the whole fraternity and sorority
out of Jon Benet they called it we're
going looking for it was set oh it was
JB and BJ JB's and BJ's it was
JonBenet's and [ __ ] was like kind of
the other part and what and what were
the snacks was it milk and pineapple
that's a deep cut it's a deep cut well I
thought what the brother was eatin when
every allegedly killed her I'm gonna say
this man I think that it's the best
thing for the Patriots to do I think
it's an ice-cold move I don't think that
he's I think he's one of the greatest
quarterbacks of all time but I think
it's his ability to take win them a
Super Bowl maybe is done I don't think
the relationship is you know it's over
he's there for 20 years be cool boss
he's there for 20 years he's also
getting a little older and he doesn't
have any help they have a good defense
but there's no offensive help you know
let him go you think he's coming to LA
do you think a guarantee comes to LA
charges he has offers from LA charges
and Tampa Bay but he has a production
studio out here he has a house here in
Bel Air
he's gonna move here so you have lebron
and tom brady both oldest [ __ ] but
they're here yeah yeah I don't know if I
mean it's like charges two years ago
remember they're they're the team
they're the [ __ ] team there's had a
bad year last year but you put Tom Brady
on there the boy is gonna be bad but
also same conferences patching my home's
so it's gonna be tough for a man to win
anything yeah and your boy who's your
Denver boy new guy quarterback all of
them true LOC drew LOC yeah do you lock
a rat now Kenny
well there's video of them sidelines
just wrapping like Soul Survivor I think
it was young jeezy song on the sideline
yeah young jeezy and called himself a
rap be on his dog Young Jeezy went to
Loyola bro I think all of New Orleans
that's true it's probably them well I
don't know Lola gets pretty urban
Baltimore Chicago New Orleans yeah
that's true Loyola Marymount hearing la
soupe yeah it's just whites hot in
that's where Jim what is this guy asking
about what is this problem sounds like
you guys are kinging him being coming
down its come to LA get your mind I
don't think that it's the best
investment for the charges are really
don't I mean I don't think it's bad but
I have a quarterback right now yeah but
I think you just go with somebody that's
good and younger I mean I don't know
somebody young there's a bunch of good
quarterbacks coming out yeah I think
you're just gonna
up with the team that loses in the first
round of the playoffs for the second
round of the house I'm not saying the
Tom Brady isn't great but do when Peyton
Manning came back for that last season
wherever that was Denver
remember the second one the second last
Super Bowl in Denver yeah but that last
season he came back with and still won a
Super Bowl it was old as [ __ ] came out
from the Colts we want a Super Bowl yeah
Chargers need to fill seats - we won one
we won one Super all we lost it went to
two Super Bowls Peyton Manning that's a
good point
I bet Tom Brady plays three games and
it's a wrap I think there's no no way no
way Broncos on that joins the Chargers
midseason that veto or Antonio Brown now
we're talking that'd be interesting
there you got weapons man two years ago
they were the [ __ ] squad people
forget I'm sure Antonio Brown will do
well in LA I don't know I just mean
problem I'm sure you know see my son me
what do you guys think what's up what's
happening to me what is the Asian
culture to think of Tom Brady do you
guys look at him as a god like white
people do or it is it but does it matter
chin doesn't watch football it chin
likes the charges cuz they used to have
a Korean kicker Danny Boy yeah I mean
they cut him they did yeah cool his name
was ku I've got the rest of his name is
cool he does like Chappell type [ __ ]
before he kicks it to no one Korean baby
you forgot the rest of his we talked
about a lot cool cool boy that man yeah
Dallas Cowboys and they have foo Yong ah
foo yung who ain't you that new guy for
Atlanta the kicker qu yang oh I think
that's who I was thinking of he's the
guy that does all the flips and [ __ ]
[ __ ] Korean Bourbon Street legend bro
he's badass he is badass dude yeah I
don't think he's playing anymore so no
yes yeah yes like I think Patriots huh
somebody picked him up some Georgia
Southern look at check this out boom
boom that's a ninja plays football
everything it's all WWE man everything
started in to WWE if this doesn't work
out he'd be the most lit Power Ranger
they got heartbeat what do you got what
do you think Chappelle I don't watch why
so there's a lot
more black quarterbacks now I know that
much that's true I like Marv Jackson MVP
yeah one that's one Brit Patrick mahomes
half you're getting worse on this one
yeah I know right he's just going down
now this name a white guy under drew
brees great-great-grandpa yeah who else
I got this song Watson Cam Newton Cam
Newton Jameis Winston you might be
looking for a job too
I don't know what they're gonna do down
there yeah I don't know I mean it's
definitely a great move it's la you know
it seemed like a lot of players like the
big-name start to come over here because
it's easy to do endorsements all of that
kind of stuff like LeBron came here his
whole production stills out here I'll
see you know he wants to do good with
the Lakers but he has his whole squad at
it productions do all that stuff he's
making movies and [ __ ] yeah can do both
yeah Tom Brady same way he has his was
it TB 20 whatever the [ __ ] it is 12 TB
12 yeah his whole production staff out
here I'm just saying it's just like what
well if you do that out here there's
more opportunity for all that you could
start a show you could start a studio
you could start all that kind of stuff
out here it seemed like more than
somewhere else you know for sure but so
yeah it's just like a lot of these guys
they come out to LA towards the end you
know smart move get paid to do your
business I think he's asking if who
would be new king of LA would it be
LeBron or would it be Tom Brady not that
he's coming to LA I think LeBron is
gonna win a championship this year with
the Lakers so yeah thank you
it's gonna be totally him and the other
best player in the league it's too much
man it's too much if they can beat the
Greek freak you want to close it out
with one relationship advice and one
King or sting let's help this the kicker
weirdo
his name's Jung ho okay huh I don't know
dude is this the kicker god I'm moving
my bird they cannot legally get my
birthday moving no you're a Pisces bro
and Jerome from Cebu Philippines almost
done enough amen brother
like a relationship advice for you guys
he's tired on Valentine's Day some guy
was sending my girl flowers and a letter
and today he sends her chocolates now
both me and my girl are medical students
getting our MD since the eye bags she
goes to another school
so my question is should I go across the
island and figure out who it is and show
them what's up
who or should I lay back my girl handle
it it's my relationship advice
buzz buzz young man this is a good
question
i-i'll do you go over to beat the dude
up you know if your girl's fine you have
a bunch of people shooting some shots no
matter what man shooting shots at some
thoughts you feel me so for him dude let
you know I wanna say anything let your
girls let's see how loyal this girl is
dude and you're young let's see how
loyal she is dude start setting a speaks
and [ __ ] also if you look more into it
why is he sending all this [ __ ] like
what's going on there dude I'm looking
more at your girl than homeboy if your
girl's fine shooters gonna shoot like
Nick Kerr you feel me you nailed it that
time I thought me too
you heard the Nick heavy on the case
he's gonna come after me man you know
hey dress like one of the bad guys in a
time to kill you know so it is there's
also really good Reverend Segal know
yeah I'm the kill remember with the hard
to kill I'm thinking and also with the
guy with Matthew McConaughey remember
that over he's a lawyer
yeah now also we just realized that and
Mick is the type of guy that knows
Steven Seagal
meet my grandma watch all of them Tommy
Lee Jones would eat that raw meat anyway
so for him you gotta get your girl now
the shooters gonna shoot dude so yella
get your girls he's entertaining the
[ __ ] why did he send flowers and what
else
but then send chocolates again yeah he
said this is two gifts because she gave
him the cold shoulder he like keep
sending it yeah I think cuz your thing
once you go over there and open up a can
of uh you know a can of Top Ramen
whatever yeah bottom ramen Asia
[Laughter]
hey don't go over the nobody can of spam
you don't help anyone never help one
person I get some ideas from people like
you really should we buy so good I broke
up me I'm addicted to drugs dude help I
said was start a podcast I think this
Pinoy fella is serious first of all this
guy's a doctor okay
and he'll obviously get her of him he
goes over there to carve that dude up it
could get nasty you know he might carve
him up and bring back the line that
stirred it may be a gangster moved
brought kill the dude and then [ __ ] him
bring him back to life and someone never
messed with your girlfriend again but I
said yeah ask your girl if she can shut
it down if she needs some help shutting
it down that's what I would say let's go
to a female perspective what do you
think I agree with that which part
all of it honestly I think you should
let her take care of it but it is also
weird that she's receiving
from a guy who probably knows that she
has a boyfriend
it's what's weird to me the first time I
if she's fine enough dude price shot a
shot he's like right she's not into it
firmus in the second time damn thanks
boo a spins like oh [ __ ] here's some
chocolates [ __ ] I don't see it like
that
you know who knows maybe the other guy
is trying to court her they are in the
Philippines that's how they do a court
down there mm-hmm
they still give like uh like royalty
what affection is the word you're
looking for Tower II know but to my
understanding when a guy wants to date a
girl in the Philippines old-school way
is him and he would gather a bunch of
his friends and he would basically go to
her house and like perform for her
that's what those white dudes were doing
basically that they would do that but in
the Philippines that's exhausting but I
think it shows a level of affection kind
of it so you might be serious you know
if you got your boys and get a rap hey
you know that's why Filipinos can sing
you dance that's true Smith a little
freestyle forbid toes don't I'm Rodney
really loves you you know we came all
the way over here and it's all for
Rodney dude and it's hard yeah there's
something nice about it yeah it's kind
of cool Chappelle what do you think man
wouldn't you tell this guy if some dude
was send your girl gifts what what would
happen Chappelle I mean I go with you
like you know talk to a homegirl first
like if it just kept going I probably
like oh then I guess that's your thing
you know are you saying like she's
entertaining it well I'm just like
that's your thing and I probably news on
now so you don't get beat up [ __ ] all
y'all
[Laughter]
don't do a somersault in here y'all beat
me up right now we want to homeboy just
kept sending your girl yes you're just
gonna give up let's you boo yeah I mean
I'm pretty I'm a lone wolf yeah you're
good yeah you're always gonna be a lone
wolf of you but hey you know if you just
every time that the any time you said
your girl is yeah every summit sometimes
everybody sits in your sand and you just
go small the chocolate she needs and
yeah we take personal offense to that to
the actor that's like if somebody sent
some fluffer nutters to your girl you
know warm cheese puffs
somebody's your girl or to shatter
baguette or if somebody set your girl oh
wait you don't have somebody sent your
girl some long johns with cream I'm
going back to Maui bro but look man I
think that this guy is gonna be fine
what was this problem again man this
guy's worried about race relations on an
island bro I say you pick up a truck
full of your Pinoy bad boys and roll
over there dude dude drift over there
crypto ass over there see what's up so
where's your flowers now yeah teaches
fella what's up man who's some
chocolates send him a thing a chocolate
probably a stupid face yeah
send it well no but send him some
chocolates man say look man yes avium
chocolates back yes a look ma'am we all
invite half of them yeah eat half of
yeah and be like this why I think of you
dude yeah do it for my girl I'll put
some secret messages in them that's a
good idea
no man I would say give or give people
your dates
mmm-hmm thanks Corona 19 think yeah
we're here man we're just surviving how
are you guys surviving you guys
surviving okay do you feel like just
load up on stuff oh yeah yep loaded up
on a bunch of spam and a bunch of ramen
Wow really mm-hmm
that's how Asians stock up I feel like I
feel like you're gonna be fine we were
like a three month issue where we
couldn't eat I feel like you're just
you're gonna be fine just by yourself
right seen spam at night that's pretty
resilient do you feel lonelier in this
time kind of time since you broke up
with your boyfriend no you know I feel
like now I can focus on myself
mm-hmm and now I there's just more food
for one person yeah yeah because you
always have to worry about like another
person oh yeah if you're with someone
now I could just focus on myself you'd
that post mates building that's a strong
independent woman hey man I'm not Steve
Kerr over here you're ruining our
birthday you ruined it I thought those
four white dudes from a simpler time
Brendan you write me like yo they're
doing it all right happy birthday man
you guys be good